avec nous maintenant alain chalifoux
président de la laiterie chalifoux
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur chalifoux
quelles émotions vous habite aujourd'hui
c'était quand même sens en tant que la
laiterie chalifoux existe avec cette
transaction quelle émotion avec vous là
le plus gros émotion c'est avec les
employés ce matin oui comment ça s'est
passé
très bien écoutez je veux le cacherai
pas là les employés qu'on va entrer en
même temps que moi d'un début d année
soit et 10 vous pouvez vous imaginer oui
et vous vous êtes le petit fils ou le
fondateur l'un fondateur si vos arrières
arrières grands parents oui mon
arrière-grand-mère
alexandrina pelti celle du fou à
démarrer l'entreprise en 1900 avant moi
je suis la quatrième génération est la
dernière génération pourrait-on dire ce
soir oui bon ça vous fait quoi ça quand
même
c'est émotif j'ai écouté en même temps
aujourd'hui même on part et avec moi il
y avait trop de santé on était les
potages charles lemoyne ensemble ok ma
mère et ma mère elle était très ému
parce que
toute la famille travaillé dans le passé
qui n'ont pas travaillé dur mais ma mère
aussi a travaillé les bureaux
administratifs dans son oeil était dans
nos résidences privées boussuge été
levée que oui c'est une page
qui étaient filmées
de notre côté ce que je veux juste vous
expliquer et à 20 de réjouissances parce
que et qui était un motif aussi ce qu'on
sait que l'entreprise d'être celle du
fou et les produits riviera vont faire
encore un autre centre oui vous en avez
donc la conviction que aujourd'hui si
c'était la bonne chose à faire mais
pourquoi fallait faire ça aujourd'hui
pour
l'excellente questions et écouter
la chose qui arrive là dedans c'est que
on aurait pu vendre à des
multinationales des grandes entreprises
- et la question c'est que nous c'était
dans un plan quelques athlètes avait
avec nous monsieur je gardais janvier
monsieur mât dans l'eau parce que je
tenais me
il fait partie intégrante de la famille
depuis 2015 je les rencontrais en 2013
la première fois puis on eu un fit wii
et fouet peut aller dans l'historique je
sais pas combien de temps j'ai mais vous
vous expliqué l'historique c'est que la
base c'est que quand qu'on a eu un fils
ensemble c'est que avec lui
lyon a marqué 40 pour saint-honoré peut
dévorer banquier un investissement
québec dans les années
2015 en 2014 mais un banquier ça amène
de l'argent
mais cela a amené de l'argent
et une confiance une confiance tout de
suite qui s'est établi entre vous deux
oui on en écoute et un six mois au moins
quelqu'un en six mois la flexibilité des
entreprises comme la nôtre de marché
national sortir 56 kg ou en six mois
tomber la meilleur produit par canadien
toutes catégories meilleurs produits des
tipis de maya marketing les petits pots
dans les produits haut de gamme d'un
échec dans les yoghourts fermes
typiquement français vous allez pas
trouvé souvent et ils n'avaient nulle
n qui faisait ce produit là qu'on a fait
une copie on a pu faire ça rapidement et
sous le radar parce qu'on arrache à
écouter la compétition dans le domaine
est-ce que vous quand on faire
l'épicerie je pense que les gens ont vu
le oui
est ce que ça ne pouvait se faire
qu'avec un groupe français quand on dit
vous passez à des intérêts étrangers des
intérêts français quand vous entendez ça
l'a tué mme kosor vous aimez pas ça pour
quoi non parce que c'est pas le bon
terme ce que j'essaie de vous expliquer
ce que monsieur m'a dont ils rendus au
québec il veut être québécois savent son
époux s'en vient c'est un canadien il
est un membre depuis 2015 il aime le
pays ont ils débarqueront paulo 50
français sont élus si cette seule
privées de canadiens ni dit là dedans
c'est d'avoir le savoir faire québécois
nos employés savent comment faire un
produit de qualité puis c'est ça qu'on
veut faire on savoir les producteurs
modestie parce qu'ils veulent faire non
plus donc mais si jaloux vous avez la
conviction pis même l'engagement de sa
part que d'abord les emplois reste que
les installations respect qu'on va
continuer à développer cette entreprise
là ok remporté au cul des nanas mairie
ils n'ont juste deux ans à franges enfin
pour une consolidation sans néron poste
est pour ça le choix de
la coopérative alsace les cantons dix
hommes alsace là on connaît pas ça ici
si qui c'est qui alsace lait ben c'est
une entreprise qui est qui qui a 60 ans
d'existence
puis quand maintenant son lit 25e en
europe ces points un gros groupe c'est
un groupe un peu plus gros que nous
sommes comme que j'étais que l'acception
excusé mais vous comprenez l'idée c'est
que eux ils ont travaillé fort pour
trouver un financement jeu mais mieux se
retrouver mais eux ce parce qu'ils ont
les mêmes valeurs que nos écrits c'est
ça qui est important ils veulent
continuer à faire un produit de qualité
puis de port de port met dans la bouche
des québécois un produit mais plutôt la
faille déguste il affecte la fin
l'afrique connaît est-ce que vous restez
engagées dans l'entreprise monsieur chen
fu panda est-ce que vous restez
impliqués dans l'entreprise moins dans
mon cas moi mais peut-être pour encore
un mois mais je veux toujours est ouvert
pour les écouter ma cousine mélanie
alain travail doit elle continue pour un
bout mais écoutez moi vous savez
peut-être entendu que monsieur le
ministre andrée lamontagne m'a donné
mandat de l'été au cul laïcité président
du cours du premier conseil
d'administration
donc je vais
pouvoir redresser mettre les fleurons
qu'on a quitté au cul vraiment c'est un
fleuron québécois que nous avons qu'on
vende mende convoquons voir croître puis
je vais peut-être de faire un peu de
consultation et le travail original
puisqu'il distribution quoi le texte que
dans le procédé de transformation
alimentaire et des tirs merci monsieur
chalifoux bonne chance merci beaucoup
merci bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit